a lot of people could relate to Brooke
Shields but she was a teen actress and
model but my oh my will working moms
relate to Brooke now as our senior news
editor Jennifer Perez found out Brooke
has her hands full hosting a series XM
radio show while raising two young girls
pick already meet act like a crazy
person is what they inspire me to do
every day there's a new challenge you
know a 13 year old and a 10 year old my
new thing is not screaming and not
screaming back at them I would engage in
an absolute fight and my husband would
say what is wrong with you why are you
fighting with them she started it I mean
I get really mature 51 year old Brooke
says she loses and sometimes balancing
work being the wife but raising two
girls but she keeps saying with this
Chris my husband calls it um
boffo find out before you freak out so
before I react I'm now trying to just
take the count to 10 smart and Berg also
has these words of wisdom for mom to be
a mall Clooney raise your twins away
from Hollywood they've got enough of
being self-absorbed with with selfies
and I don't know all that well that kind
of stuff I mean that's enough already
you sort of don't want to add Hollywood
to it so please join me each week to
talk about ah life parenting fashion
currently the host of her own Sirius XM
radio show Brooke Shields now she knows
all about growing up the spotlight at 15
years old nothing came between her and
accountants there was the Blue Lagoon in
1980 and then she made headlines for her
friendship with Michael Jackson
Michael and I have been friends for a
while are we gonna see the two of you on
the tabloids now I'm sure they will if
before anything he's one of my closest
friends and I love him for that so what
does Brooks say now about Michael's
daughter parish Jackson who was pursuing
acting and modeling just surround
yourself by people you trust and not
just people who say yes
you